wir kommen von dunkelheit kommen wir zu
etwas schönes etwas sonnigen denn die
freibadsaison sie hat begonnen die
ersten gäste
sie können sich über wunderbares wetter
freuen allerdings müssen sich auch die
gäste im freibad an corona regeln halten
es gibt zugangsbeschränkungen und der
sprung ins kühle nass der kann nicht so
einfach spontan stattfinden denn es
werden bestimmte zeit karten verteilt
und auch der abstand im wasser der muss
gewahrt werden einer der ersten besucher
im freibad lörick ist bild-reporter jürn
karstädter ja die freibäder heute wieder
eröffnet 20 grad ist denn schon viel los
bei dir ja guten tag hier aus düsseldorf
nach sachsen ist nordrhein westfalen das
zweite land was seine freibäder eröffnet
wir stehen hier vor dem freibad die
betonung liegt auf vor weil es gibt eine
zulassungsbeschränkung auf 400 personen
die gleichzeitig in barth sein dürfen
und diese zahl wurde allein durch die
vorverkäufe heute morgen schon erreicht
und wir haben deswegen leider keinen
zutritt mehr bekommen
hier ist es so geregelt 400 menschen
parallel in vier stunden es gibt
sozusagen drei zeitfenster 1 war bereits
am morgen 1 wird dann in den
abendstunden noch eingerichtet und für
den kompletten tag sind alle karten alle
1200 karten ausverkauft
im wasser gilt dass die acht bahnen die
hier sind die sind geteilt es darf immer
nur in bestimmte richtungen geschwommen
werden so dass es da kaum zu kontakt
kommt und wir haben ein bisschen das
geschehen heute hier beobachtet die
menschen halten sich daran
das gelände ist auch sehr sehr groß es
sind stehen alleine 100000 quadratmeter
liegefläche zur verfügung
und da kann man sich ganz leicht
ausrechnen dass bei 400 personen
zeitgleich der hat jeder sehr viel platz
und auch deutlich mehr als die zehn
quadratmeter die gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben sind hier das können wir
auch hinter dir sehen trotz der vielen
menschen sieht daher sehr entspannt aus
bei dir im freibad danke dir erstmal für
diese information wie man corona und wie
man auch den badespaß handeln kann in
diesen zeiten görg karstadt ganz
herzlichen dank für diese eindrücke